Dim dim, da da dam dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da dam, da gerade im Kino, haben uns den neuen Fluttergrip angeschaut. Holy shit! Javier Badem! Holy shit! Badem! Babing, babang, babam! Sag ich mal, ey. Aber ob Hans Zimmer dann auch mal so zu Hause sitzt und hat ein Ohr rum davon und singt die ganze Zeit so, Flucht der Karibik, Flucht der Karibik und Johnny Depp und Javier Badem. Ich glaube, ich schon. Ich glaube, das ist die grösste Anerkennung, die ein Komponist haben kann. Halt! Herzlich willkommen zum Zügel an die Gags. Zügel an die Gags. Zügel an die Gags. Folge das Podcast-Uvo. Wir sind wieder da, wir haben überlebt die grosse 2017er Pfingstfeier. Pfingsten! Alter, Pfingsten, Alter, holy shit. Diese Folge wird euch präsentiert von acht Flaschenmarte, die jeder von uns zugenommen hat. Alter Vater. Wenn jemand vielleicht ein bisschen merkt, ey, ich hatte meinen Pfingsthut, glaube ich, zwei Wochen am Stück an. Der Pfingstbaum hat gebrannt, sag ich dir, der hat gebrannt, die ganze Stadt war dann am Pfingstbaum versammelt, klar, wie man das halt so macht, haben dann diese ganzen Blender, die Pfingstbänder am Pfingstbaum befestigt. Was hast du zu Pfingsten bekommen? Wie immer ein Schwein. Tatsächlich? Ja, aber das ist doch Standard. Die meisten Leute bekommen ein Schwein zu Pfingsten geschenkt, um es dann zu essen mit der ganze Familie, ein Schwein, in dem ein Trutern gestopft ist, in dem eine Weihnachtsgans gestopft ist. Und meine Pfingstzahl dieses Jahr ist die 19. 17.
Ey, fast! Beides Primzahlen.
Primzahlen!
Drei, sieben, achtzehn!
Ey, das Primzahlenfest kommt jetzt noch.
Ja, das stimmt.
Da freue ich mich auch schon drauf.
Du hast gerade im Vorgespräch, wo wir überlegt haben...
Auf dem Weg von unserem Büro zum Studio.
Das ist ja alles nicht spontan, es gibt einen Sendeablauf, wir überlegen uns die Gags vorher mit unseren Autoren und dann hast du gesagt, in diesem Vorgespräch, worum es darum ging, den Content ein bisschen anzuführen, hast du gesagt, ja, wir machen halt gut 20 Minuten heute. Darauf wollte ich mal kurz eingehen. Was bedeutet, das habe ich noch nie verstanden, wenn man sagt, eine gute Stunde, meint man dann mehr als eine Stunde, meint man leicht weniger als eine Stunde, aber meint man um eine Stunde herum. Weil wenn du sagst, ja, lass es mal gut zwölf Uhr gewesen sein oder es hat ungefähr eine gute Stunde gedauert, was meint man dann, warum sagt man nicht eine Stunde? Einerseits kann gut ungefähr heißen, das war so um
gut zwölf Uhr rum. Aber ungefähr ist doch nicht
gut. Richtig, aber ich glaube, in der Hinsicht
heißt es, ich würde
sagen, auch nach dem Schnitt
noch solide 20 Minuten.
Was meinst du? Also gut
ist der Vorbegriff von solide.
Solide ist noch besser als gut.
Wie lange habt ihr
wie lange habt ihr ich möchte jetzt nicht ins Zotige gehen, sorry, wie lange, Florian hat seine zotige Phase gerade. Er ist ein bisschen obszön unterwegs. Ich weiß, ich weiß. Doch, heute hat er sich einen Finger durch die Hose vorne gesteckt und alle dachten, es wird sein Penis und er hat sich rüber, kaputt gelacht. Das stimmt. Ich habe auch mit der linken Hand
habe ich so, wie wenn so ein Italiener Molto Bene
sagt, wie auf so einem Pizzakarton, habe ich so
einen Kreis gebildet mit Zeigefinger
und Daumen und habe dann den rechten Mittelfinger
in einer rapiden Abfolge von
Stössen durch das entstehende
Praktikantin Ulliana wurde ganz rot.
Das stimmt, aber nicht im Gesicht.
Baum, baum, baum, baum,
widerlich, widerlich, man weiß nicht genau, wie es gemeint war. Zwei. Ich würde sagen, also, kurz nochmal, es gibt auch knapp eine Stunde. Und knapp eine Stunde ist weniger als eine Stunde, oder? Es hat knapp eine Stunde gedauert. Wenn ich jetzt einfach so sage, wie lange habt ihr getanzt und ich sage, gute 20 Minuten, Dann sage ich, 20 Minuten, oft hat man das Problem, dass Dinge als Übertreibungen verstanden werden, wenn sie es gar nicht sind. Zum Beispiel, sag mal, ey, und dann habe ich drei Stunden lang auf den Zug gewartet. Leute verstehen oft, ah, er hat eine lange Zeit auf den Zug gewartet, aber du möchtest sagen, nein, ich habe wirklich drei Stunden lang. Oft sagt man auch so, boah mein Gott, ich stand am Lidl wieder drei Stunden lang in der Schlange. Dann meint man, ja, dann meint man wahrscheinlich nicht drei Stunden. Selten drei Stunden. So, aber das Problem ist... Obwohl die Kassenverhältnisse beim Lidl wirklich unter aller Sau sind. Ist ein anderes Thema, dazu unser Lidl-Podcast sei empfohlen, aber das ist tatsächlich so ein Ding, was sagt man, wenn man tatsächlich drei Stunden lang in der Lidl-Kasse stand. Da muss man dann sagen, Sachen wie gut, ich stand gute drei Stunden in der... Aber wohl jetzt auch. Nee, dann nimmst du mich ernst. Du kommst nicht aus der Klinge. Ich stand gute drei Stunden in der Lidl-Warteschlange, dann würde ich sagen, was, echt? Weil das klingt nicht nach einer Übertreibung. Ich stand knapp drei Stunden in der Lidl. Diese ganzen Wörter, die sind alle unbrauchbar, werf die mal weg in einer Übertreibung. Das Problem ist, Ironie frisst ja alles auf. Egal welche Verteidigungsmassnahmen, du, der Ironie oder Übertreibung, was jetzt beide ähnliche Stilmittel sind, egal welche Hindernisse du versuchst, dir den Weg zu werfen, sie fressen es ja auf. Also auch so Sachen wie Kappa, dass man im Streaming-Kosmos sagt man, oder im Weiteren Gaming-Kosmos sagt man Kappa, wenn etwas ironisch gemeint ist. Aber dann fangen Leute an, das auch wiederum ironisch zu sagen.
Und auch die Ironie ironisch, und du kommst,
du hast verloren. Aber in dieser Falle, das merken wir auch selber
beim Erstellen dieses Podcasts, wir haben schon so
manche Sachen, also wirklich
manche gesellschaftliche Probleme haben wir mit dem
Ziermesser genau,
sagen wir mal, euch offenbart und dahingelegt
und wir haben die Gesellschaft auseinandergeplückt,
aber man würde es uns halt niemals glauben,
weil wir halt diese Ironie, diese Ironie, das Damoklesschwert der Ironie bei uns hängen haben. Aber es ist nicht mal Damoklesschwert, es ist so ein Schwert, was die ganze Zeit immer so reinsticht, an so einem Gweband. Ja, es ist eher so ein Zahnstocher mit einem Stück Käse drauf, wo die Weintraube schon runtergefallen ist, sowas in der Richtung. Aber du hast ja tatsächlich, ich glaube, das war auch das Problem von Hitler, der meinte so, tausendjähriges Reich und alle so. Das war das Problem von Hitler? Hauptproblem. Und alle so, ja, ein langes Reich halt. Und er so, nee, ein tausendjähriges Reich. Metaphorisch für ein langes Reich. Nee, schreibt bitte, genau tausend Jahre. Was machen wir im Jahr tausend Jahre? Herr Hitler, ich habe noch kurz eine Frage. Also die ganzen Belege, die gehen jetzt auch nur bis zum Jahr tausend von heute. Ja, also. Warum reden Sie so anders, wenn Sie nicht in der Öffentlichkeit stehen? Ich muss meine Stimme schon. Okay. Also, die Frage ist ja, was passiert im Jahre 2933, dann ist Schluss, dann ist Finito, Fiene, ich sag, hallo, ich bin der Führer, das sind dann Schluss, Punkt 2933 ist hier Schicht im Schacht, Freunde, auf den Tag. Sie sagen das, Herr Hitler, oder? Ja. Sorry, eigentlich ist das meine normale Stimme. Das ist Ihre normale Stimme? Das ist meine Stimme, wenn ich versuche, meine andere Stimme zu schonen. Und wenn Sie wütend sind, was machen Sie dann für eine Stimme? Ach jetzt aber, sag einmal! Ich komme aus dem Schein. Unabhängig davon. Im Ausland sprechen Sie mit Ihrer Freundin, sprechen Sie auch ganz anders. Lass alle Briefköpfe noch mal einstampfen. Ihr habt das komplett missverstanden. Ihr habt gesagt, ein heiliges, sehr langes Reich. Ich meine wirklich tausendjährig. Ich meine das wirklich so. Nur weil es eine gerade Zahl ist. Wusstest du zum Beispiel, dass das erste Mal, als der Mount Everest gemessen wurde, haben die den gemessen und dann war der, glaube ich, sagen wir mal, Punkt 300 Meter.
Oh, das ist lustig.
Aber auf den Punkt. Und dann haben die gesagt, das glaubt uns niemand und deswegen haben die die Zahl gefälscht und haben halt so was wie 3000.
Haben die so einen grossen Hammer genommen und haben die Gipfel abgeschlagen.
Und dann haben die, glaube ich, so was wie 3004 Meter.
Das ist lustig.
Obwohl der Punkt 3000 Meter, aber alle sagen, ja, da habt ihr ja gerundet, das ist keine akkute Zahl.
Das ist wirklich lustig. Das ist ein riesiges Problem. Das ist genauso, wenn jemand irgendwie die Zeit messen muss für jemanden, die die Luft anhält und dann kommt der hoch und du sagst zwei Minuten, er sagt, du hast nicht aufgepasst, du hast die ganze Zeit nur auf deine Handgelenke kauft, ohne dass es eine Uhr ist, kann ich dein Handgelenk mal sehen. Ich glaube auch, im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde kommen, angenommen man nimmt mal alle Zahlen der Welt, und je nachdem, gauscher Normalverteilung, was kommt am häufigsten vor und alles kommt einigermaßen gleichmässig vor und die Chance, dass eine Zahl auftritt, ist genauso groß, dass die andere Zahl auftritt.
Ich glaube, es kommen verhältnismässig wenig gerade Zahlen im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde vor.
Weil ich glaube, weil die meisten...
Extrem interessanter Fakt.
Ja, ohne Scheiss, weil ich glaube, wir sind Nischen, Nischen, Nischen-Podcast jetzt.
Aber ich glaube, dass die meisten Leute nicht zugeben, dann, gut, du hattest so und so viele Hotdogs in fünf Minuten gegessen? Nee, da hast du aber nicht richtig aufgepasst. Gibt es eigentlich einen Weltrekord für den erbärmlichsten Versuch eines Weltrekordes? Also der schlechteste Weltrekordversuch aller Zeiten. Ich glaube, irgendwo an Regel zwei, das Genussbuch der Rekorde ist, keine Meta-Gags. Das ist, glaube ich, so Regel zwei. Regel eins ist keine schlechten Rekorde. Keine negativen Rekorde. Regel zwei ist keine Meta-Gags in diesem Buch. Aber sowas wie der dümmste Mensch gibt es doch, oder? Wie soll man das messen? Das ist doch objektiv nicht messbar. Klar IQ, ja gut, dann kannst du halt sagen, der niedrigste IQ. Hast du mal einen IQ-Test gemacht? Warum macht man das in Deutschland gar nicht?
Ja, ich habe einen IQ von Lisa Simpson. War nicht der offizielle IQ-Test, glaube ich, aber auf jeden Fall, die Seite sah seriös aus. Ich bin orange. Nee, aber es stimmt. Aber IQ, ich glaube, je dümmer man ist, desto ... Sagt er IQ wissen. Nein, doch, Gegenthese. Gut, akzeptiert. Je schlauer man ist, desto mehr möchte man sich darin bestätigt wissen, ergo seinen IQ-Wissen. Je klüger man ist, desto weniger wichtig ist einem die objektive eigene Klugheit. Weil je mehr man weiß, desto mehr kennt man die Limitationen von sich selbst und hält sich eher dumm. Nicht dumm, aber man weiß, es ist vielleicht nicht so wichtig. Wenn du dumm bist, willst du auf jeden Fall einen Beweis dafür haben, dass du vielleicht klug bist. Und je dümmer du bist, desto klüger denkst du bist zu sein. Das glaube ich nicht. Überproportional, nicht direkt. Gegenthese zu meiner Gegenthese. Je schlauer du bist, desto mehr weißt du um die Schwächen dieser sogenannten objektiven Qualitäts- Intelligenzquotient-Messungssysteme. Deswegen willst du das nicht wissen. Antwort auf deine erste Gegenthese. Je schlauer du bist, desto mehr Erfolg hast du, desto weniger bist du darauf angewiesen, dich an eine objektive Zahl deiner Klugheit zu hängen. Wir haben die Hörer verloren. Ach, ganz angenehm eigentlich. Wir waren so ein paar Wochen nicht da. Aber ich sag mal so, wir haben Pfingsten genossen und draußen war auch schönes Wetter, es ist sommerlich geworden. Ich wollte mal ein Rezept loswerden. Ich habe immer gesagt, ich habe mich immer beneidet. Also so Leute wie du und auch manchmal Jan Böhmermann, die dann so Rezepte raushauen. Und ich konnte da nicht mitreden, weil ich bin, du haust mal ein paar Rezepte raus. Das war ich diese Grillbananas, die Grillbananas. Ach so, ja, Grillbananas. Ja, so, und ich habe nie ein Rezept auf meinem Handgelenk schütteln können. Und deswegen wollte ich jetzt mal ein Rezept sagen. Und zwar habe ich am Wochenende... Töpfe pfahnen, Herd auf fünf und Salz bereit, hier ist Steffans Küchentipps. Rezepte! Und zwar selbstgemachte Zitrone-Ingwer-Limonade. Ihr nehmt ein Zeigefinger-grosses Stück Ingwer, schneidet das in kleine Stückchen, nehmt zwei Esslöffel Zucker... Man muss jetzt sagen, Stefan hat die grössten Finger der Welt. Ja, nehmt ihr vielleicht zwei Stücke Ingwer, schneidet das in kleine Stückchen, nehmt zwei Esslöffel Zucker. Man muss jetzt sagen, Stefan hat die grössten Finger der Welt.
Ja, nehmt ihr vielleicht zwei Stücke Ingwer, schneidet das in kleine Stückchen, macht zwei Esslöffel Zucker drauf, dann den Saft einer Zitrone und gebt ein Liter kochendes Wasser hinzu in diesen Topf. Lass das Ganze für zwei Stunden lang stehen, dann das Ganze schön in ein Glas mit Eiswürfeln und dann noch ein bisschen Minze, so Minzblätter drauf.
Und das schmeckt mega gut. selbstgemachte Zitrone-Ingwerlingbonade. Und ich sag mal so, Verwandte, Freunde waren begeistert. Ich habe mir so einen Limonadenstand aufgebaut, schön zwei Euro draufgeschrieben pro und dann kam die Nachbarschaft vorbei und hat sich in diesen hitzigen Tagen eine Erfrischung geholt. These, je mehr Zutaten etwas hat, desto schlechter ist es. Ich sage, eine Zitronenlimonade ist immer besser als eine Zitronenlingmer. Habe ich probiert. Ich habe nebenbei aus der gleichen These heraus, habe ich nämlich nebenbei den Versuch gemacht, normale amerikanische Limonade einfach nur mit Zitrone und Zucker zu machen. Zucker braucht du halt einfach, um diesen Säuregehalt irgendwie zu kompensieren. Und tatsächlich fehlt was. Es fehlt so ein bisschen so eine Schärfe. Und man nimmt euch ein bisschen weniger irgendwas, den schmeckst du gar nicht mehr so raus, aber der macht einfach so einen wohligen Teppich da drunter. So einen wohligen Beigeschmack bringt der halt. So ein bisschen Schärfe rein, aber es ist zwar so ein bisschen deftiger. Es ist aber echt interessant und ich will es ja gar nicht auf dieses Hipster-Köln-Ehrenfeld-Bashing aufspringen, aber wenn man hier zum Beispiel irgendwo eine Eisdiele gibt, es werden immer mehr Eissorten mit mehreren Komponenten. Früher gab es halt, also früher, so gab es halt Kirsche, Joghurt, halt so einzelne Worte, und jetzt ist es halt so Ingwer, Minze, Salbei. Und ich will überhaupt nicht darauf eingehen, dass das jetzt irgendwie uncool ist oder Bashing oder so, es ist mir nur rein objektiv aufgefallen, dass die
Mehrkomponenteneiscreme
in Mode ist, wo
ich mir überdenke so, wer die
das ist eigentlich ein Zugeständnis,
dass es nicht ganz so geil ist, weil
eigentlich es hätte schon geil sein
müssen, bevor du die Salbei dazu
tust. Da mach Salbei, da mach
von mir aus eine Salbei Eis, das aber dann halt
richtig geil nach Salbei schmeckt und vermische es
nicht mit anderen Sachen, weil am Ende ist es dann nur so
Vielen Dank. sein müssen, bevor du die Salbei dazu tust. Da mach Salbei, da mach von mir aus eine Salbei Eis, das aber dann halt richtig geil nach Salbei schmeckt und
vermische es nicht mit anderen Sachen, weil am Ende ist es dann nur so,
ja, es ist halt so von beiden
so ein bisschen was. Und vor allem verlierst du auch Leute,
weil, also bei mir ist es bei Smoothies immer so,
dann stehe ich vor so einem grünen Smoothie
und dann steht da drin,
wow, geil, Banane,
cool, Apfel, wow, geil,
Kirsche ist auch noch dabei, was, Spinat, verloren. Bei dem Roten stehst du dann dabei und denkst dir, wow, geil, Himbeere, wow, geil, Johannisbeere, wow, geil, Stachelbeere, what, rote Beete? Und du hast immer eine so eine Zutat, die dich rauskegelt einfach und dann hast du keinen Bock mehr auf diesen Smoothie. Und es ist ein bisschen aber dieses Hipster-Ding, weil die meisten Hipster, die trinken das dann trotzdem. Weil es geht weniger darum, dass du dir selber einen Gefallen tust, als darum, was du gerade nach außen präsentierst. Ja, das stimmt natürlich, aber ich glaube... Aber auch, ich will nicht bashen. Nee, nee, ich will nicht bashen, auf gar keinen Fall. Aber ich glaube, immer mehr Hersteller reagieren ja da auch drauf, auf diese Bedenken, die du ja gerade... Und wollen Hipster. Und wollen die jetzt das verarschen, meinst du? Und schreiben dann zum Beispiel drauf so,
ja, Apfel, Kirsche, Erdbeer,
Mango, Rhabarber,
in Klammern, aber das schmeckt man nicht so stark,
raus, Minze, Zimt,
sowas, einfach, weil sie wissen, das ist
problematisch, so dass sie schreiben, sie,
aber nicht so viel, Leute, keine Sorge,
keine Sorge, schmeckt man nicht so sehr raus.
Ja. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wo es herkommt, wo ich meine, mein Gott, das ist alles ist so alles cool. Seid einfach, wie ihr meint zu sein. Du bist ja Käpt'n Obstsalat. Du ballerst ja jeden zweiten Tag irgendwie einen Obstsalat rein, wo ich mir einfach denke, These, ich würde lieber 20 Kirschen essen, als 10 Kirschen und 10 Erdbeeren, als einen roten Salat. Ich bin das übergegangen und dachte mir, ein ausgewogener Salat sieht gut aus.
Also da brauchst du aber auch dann anstrengend viele Zutaten.
Und ich bin eben dazu übergegangen, einfach das, was ich am liebsten mag, Himbeeren und Bananen zusammen zu würfeln.
Und das habe ich dann genommen.
Dann sagen Leute, also ein komischer Obstsalat, aber es ist einfach das, was mir am besten geschmeckt.
Das sind einfach die besten zwei Zutaten.
Es ist dann vielleicht kein Salat, streng genommen, aber ich meine, ich esse dafür, dass es mir gefällt. Ich glaube, diese Mischsorten sind eine Reaktion auf die Entschluss, die Entscheidungsmüdigkeit von vielen Konsumenten, die einfach sich nicht entscheiden können, will ich jetzt die Bananen oder will ich die Ingwer-Eiscreme, also nehme ich die Bananen-Ingwer, weil sie immer denken, es gibt einen Mehrwert Mehrwert. Da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, sich falsch zu entscheiden, geringer, weil du mehr Stichproben nimmst. Und deswegen glaube ich, wird es mehr genommen, gar nicht weil es besser ist, sondern weil die Leute eher Fehler vermeiden wollen. Zu sagen, ich habe mich für Bananen entschieden, ich hätte eigentlich Joghurt gewollt. Aber die Eiscreme selbst ist vielleicht besser, wenn sie nur Einzelsorten sind. Einfach mal auch dazu stehen, zu sagen, hey, ich will heute ein fucking Erdbeereis und nicht ein Erdbeerkirscheis. Heute Erdbeere, was ist denn schlecht an der Erdbeere? Also diese ganze Mischmasch an Zutaten ist die Reaktion an die Entscheidungsskepsis der modernen Gesellschaft. Richtig. Und deswegen könnt ihr dem entgegenarbeiten, indem ihr einfach straight sagen, auch mal sagen fünf Kugeln Banane. Ey, die diese Pause hat uns nicht gut getan. Wir fangen an, Thesen zu stellen, komisches Deutsch zu sprechen, so ein intellektuelles Deutsch, weil es uns auch nicht gut steht, und wir auch plötzlich anfangen langsam zu sprechen, einfach. Ja, aber du sagst ja, was man über Pfingsten sagt, ne? Tatsächlich, ich war früher als Kind jedes Jahr in Italien im Urlaub und da gab es natürlich auch immer Eis, viel Gelato und da gab es dann manchen Eisdien, weil das war auch so ein Touristenort, wo halt einfach viele Deutsche waren und ich glaube, da ist das Problem auch von vielen Eisständen, dass sie sich abheben müssen von anderen Eisläden. Und das ist ganz klar. Und deswegen gab es eine Eisdiele, die auch genau nur deswegen von uns immer besucht wurde, und zwar, weil es das Konzept von halben Kugeln gab. Eine Kugel kostet einen Euro, aber du kannst halbe Kugeln kaufen. Du kannst also sagen, ich hätte gern halbe Kugel Schoko, halbe Kugel Vanille und zahlst dann ein Euro dafür, dass du dann eine Kugel hast. Und wir haben irgendwann herausgefunden, dass zwei halbe Kugeln mehr sind als eine ganze Kugel. Also nimmst du zwei halbe Kugeln Zitrone. Exakt. Genau das haben wir angefangen zu machen. Aber dann sagt der doch, nee, dann nimm doch einfach eine ganze. Wir haben nämlich gesagt, ja, ich hätte gerne bitte eine halbe Kugel Banane und eine halbe Kugel Banane. Oder, oh, dann bist du ja ein Arschloch. Du kannst aber auch so tun, als du dich vertan. Ich hätte gerne eine halbe Kugel Banane, ach, habe ich halbe gesagt, eine ganze Kugel Banane. Und dann macht er vielleicht noch eine ganze drauf, dann hast du eine halbe Kugel, was mein Gag gerade komplett ruiniert hat, aber wir schauen mal, was es führt. Wir haben uns das Eis ercheatet und dachten uns, wir sind die fucking Besten der Welt, weil wir diesen Glitch rausgefunden haben. Dem Typ ist das scheißegal, das heisst es nichts wert.
Ja toll, das ist er mittlerweile in Ruinen getrieben
und ganz, ganz
Norditalien mit ihm.
Generell, ich weiß nicht, warum das nicht mehr Leute
verstehen, gerade Lieferservices.
Wenn ihr einen Lieferservice betreibt,
dann
es gibt einen Lieferservice,
der liefert immer mehr,
als man bestellt.
Und ich dachte mir, das ist das Beste, was man machen kann. Das ist so klug, weil das ist die beste Werbung, die man überhaupt nur machen kann. Es gibt für den Konsumenten, für den Besteller kein besseres Erlebnis, als mehr zu bekommen, als man möchte. Und es ist ein Sushi-Laden, und gerade ich glaube als Sushi-Laden, weil da gibt es ja tausend verschiedene Maki-Rollen und Gedöns. Der hat immer was übrig. Jeden Tag am Tagesende hat der was übrig, weil der macht halt 50 Eier, 50 Spargel, 50 Gurken, 50 Kiwi, Sushi, so und dann bleibt was dann möglich. Für den ist es doch scheißegal, einfach da noch so vier Rollen dazu. Und du denkst dir nämlich, weil du gerade bei Lieferservice musst du lange darauf warten, dass was kommt. Das heißt, deine Erwartungshaltung ist hoch. Das Schlimmstmögliche, was passiert ist, wenn du was falsch oder zu wenig kriegst. Aber im Gegenteil, was mega gut ist, wenn du zu viel kriegst. Und ich glaube mittlerweile nicht mehr, dass das ein Fehler ist, sondern der das kalkuliert macht. Ein Fingerzeig auf die Wegwerfgesellschaft. Aber ich würde immer wieder dort bestellen. Und ich rate jedem von euch, es ist das Beste, wenn du irgendwie bei Amazon was bestellst und dann ist da noch was Bonus dabei. Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ein Stück gerade. Dann schreiben Sie sich ein, kannst du das bitte zurückschicken und dann bist du Riesenaufwand, du musst in die Post gehen. Ich meine, nur kleiner Tipp, kleiner Tipp. Letztens wollte ich zum Beispiel Gulasch bestellen und dann ist mir aufgefallen, du bist der merkwürdigste Mensch der Welt, dass wenn man, sogar veganes Gulasch, kannst du kommen, ich habe vergessen, aber ich habe dann eingegeben, Gulasch, ich habe eingegeben, ich habe zu dir doch gesagt, niemand bestellt Gulasch, du bist ein Riesenidiot, du bist ein Riesenarschloch, da habe ich noch andere Schimpfwerder benutzt. Warum haben Leute was gegen Gulasch, das verstehe ich nicht. Niemand bestellt Gulasch. Ich habe letztens Madman gesehen und ich glaube in der sogar ersten oder zweiten Folge von Madman sind die zusammen essen, er und seine Frau und sie bestellt sich dann beim Restaurant dann irgendwie so einen Fisch mit Spargel und halt irgend so ein feines Gericht. So abfällig gegen Fischplatz. Nein, aber nee, ganz im Gegenteil, Fisch ist ein tolles, tolles Gericht, das kompliziert zu beurten ist. Und er, Don Draper, der per Definition coolste Typ der Welt, was bestellt er sich? Gulasch. Und da dachte ich mir, geil, ich bestelle mir auch ein Gulasch. Allein so vom Klang her, also selbst der, der sich einen Namen ausgerollt für den Gulasch, der hat sich auch schon gesagt, es ist Gulasch, es ist auch so ein Wegwerfgeräusch. Ich glaube, Eintöpfe generell haben einfach einen niedrigen Status. Ich würde mir auch in dem Restaurant nie eine Suppe oder was Eintopfiges bestellen, weil ich immer das Gefühl habe, es ist das nicht wert, weil in einem Restaurant willst du irgendwas bestellen, was du selber nicht machen kannst. Ich meine, ich kann auch keinen Gulasch kochen. Aber so ein bisschen hat das was vom Wortklang zu tun. Überleg mal, Sangria ist halt auch nur so die Früchtereste und die Cocktailreste eigentlich zusammengemixt. Und dann war das halt so dieser billigste Trunk, der dann entstanden ist. Und den hat man dann irgendwann angefangen zu verkaufen. Und es heißt aber Sangria. Deswegen dann bestellst du dir den Sangria und fühlst dich gut damit. Aber ein Eintopf, was da früher auch mal so, dass alles zusammengeworfen war, was es dann irgendwann gab. Es hat auch, glaube ich, einen anderen Namen im Mittelalter gehabt, aber wo dann einfach alles zusammengeworfen war, was irgendwie übergeblieben ist. Die ganzen Reste. Eintopf, ja. Stimmt, der eine Topf, wo das reingegangen ist. Aber tatsächlich, ich kann meinen Erfahrungsbericht mitteilen. Und zwar, wenn man Gulasch liefern eingibt bei Google, kommt man auf der dritte Suchergebnis ist Lieferando.de und zwar auf Lieferando.de slash Gulasch findet man ein Rezept für ein Gulasch auf einer Seite von einem Liefersörer. Das ist wie, als ob du bei der Post eingibst, wie schicke ich ein Paket und das ist eine Anleitung, wie du am besten Taubenzüchtest, Brieftaubenzüchtest, um es selber zu machen. Es ist so bescheuert, weil es ist so dumm und es hilft einem auch gar nicht. Das Letzte, was man haben will, wenn man Gulasch bestellen möchte, ist ein Rezept, wo man sich so, das ist das absolute Gegenteil. Vor allem, glaub mir nicht, dass man zuerst auf den Gedanken ist, ich könnte es auch selber machen, dann proaktiv entschieden hat, es doch zu bestellen und dann wieder das selber zu machen. Ich kann selbst meine Hände verwenden und dann einfach nur so ein Wort, Sie haben Hände. Ja, scheiße, stimmt. Ja, fick, könnte ich jetzt auserben. Ich war komplett enttäuscht, ich war komplett durch den Wind und ich habe im Endeffekt keinen Gulasch bestellt, weil es einfach so deprimierend ist, wenn selbst ein Lieferdienst kapituliert und sagt, mach selber, Alter, es ist wirklich für uns besser, du machst es selber, als dass wir uns darum kümmern, deinen Scheiß Gulasch zu bekommen. Es wollen also, These, es wollen so wenig Leute Gulasch haben, dass es sich für diese Lieferservices, allein fürs Image, mehr lohnt, ein Rezept für Gulasch zu schreiben, um Leute zumindest ein Service-Ding mitzugeben, um sie vielleicht wieder auf die Seite zu locken, als wirklich aktiv dafür zu sorgen, dass man Gulasch verschicken kann. These, je mehr Rezepte von etwas es gibt, desto weniger wird es selbst gemacht. Das ist Gegenthese, das Gegenteil von dem, was du gerade gesagt hast. Akzeptiert. Dankeschön. Wir sind aus der Zeit, ich habe es mal vorgeworfen, dass wir immer die gleiche Meinung hätten. So sehen wir, wir diskutieren das dann nicht aus, aber wir sind offensichtlich nicht immer der gleichen Meinung. Für mich haben Rezepte eine abschreckende Wirkung. Immer wenn
ich irgendwie denke, ach jetzt geil mal Tzatziki
machen und ein Rezept
und dann sind es allein schon acht Punkte, dann sage ich, ne lasse ich,
kaufe ich. So, ich habe noch nie ein Rezept
gesehen, was meine Freude
etwas zu machen erhöht hat. Es hat es immer
erniedrigt. Und wenn die Motivation nicht wahnsinnig
war. Es sei denn, du hast es erstaunlich wenig Zutaten, die du alle
da hast, dann hast du diesen freudigen Aspekt.
Was hat die niedrigsten Zutaten? Panna Cotta zum Beispiel ist Sahne und Gelatine. Nicht mehr. Ich dachte immer, wow, Panna Cotta, irgendwie was total Abgefahrenes. Warum verdient es dann einen eigenen Namen? Ich glaube, es ist doch noch was an. Wir wissen sehr wenig darüber. Doch, Panna Cotta ist Sahne und Gelatine. Warum verdient das dann eigenen Namen? Vielleicht heißt es das auf Italienisch. Panna Cotta? Panna? Penne Panna? Haben wir schon mal unsere berühmte Anti-Pasti-Pasti-Diskussion eigentlich geführt? Oh, ey, das ist gefährlich. Das ist richtig gefährlich. Ernsthaft, wirklich, kein Scheiß. Das ist wirklich eine gefährliche Sache. Ich würde es nicht anpassen. Vorsicht. Aber es ist das Gegenteil von Anti. Ich würde wirklich aufpassen. Was heißt Anti auf Italienisch? Fangen wir mal so an. Gegen. So. Oder meinst du andersrum jetzt? Nee. Contra. Ist mir auch ein zu heißes Eisen. Anti, pasti und pasti und Feminismus sind zwei Dinge, will in diesem Podcast. Ey, wisst ihr, was mich so richtig am Islam abfuckt?
Florentins Hasecke!
Leute, was ihn so richtig am Islam abfuckt?
Ey, fucking...
Aber man muss ja auch mal sagen, dass...
Mein Gott, nur weil ich einmal...
Aber es ist doch so, es ist doch, schau doch mal hin Biiiiiiiip Genozid Biiiiiiip Das war Florentins Hassecke. Man muss auch mal ein bisschen politische Stellung beziehen. Nee, ich finde, du hast auch ein paar richtige Punkte angesprochen. Ja, es stimmt, es stimmt. Ich war am Wochenende im Gartencenter, frag mich warum. Ich sehe schon wieder, deine Augen haben gezuckt. Ich war am Wochenende im Gartencenter und mir ist aufgefallen, und da möchte ich mal wirklich eine ernsthafte Frage an Leute mit Garten da draußen stellen, aus persönlichem Interesse, weil erschreckenderweise waren 50% dieses gut sortierten Gartencenters waren diese Statuen, die man im Garten hat, wo ich mir dachte, wer kauft sowas, mit diesen kleinen Gargoyles. So wirklich, wo man denkt, wow, wo man mal ganz kurz dazu, diese Gargoyles, die man kennt, auch von so Jugendromanen, so wenn man diese, angenommen so Cover, genau, von Jugendromanen, wo man dann diese Säulen hat und da oben drauf ist so eine Fledermaus, so ein Gargoyle, so ein Grinch. Und dann diese Dinger, so Kobolde. Und das war wirklich, 50% dieses Ladens, und es waren ganz normale Dena Gartencenter, waren halt diese Steinfiguren. Dena? Dena. Dena, D-E-H-N-E-R. Und das habe ich mich gefragt, wer kauft so was? Weil was ist das? Ich fand das so beeindruckend, dass wirklich offensichtlich das so gekauft wird, dass man wirklich 50% des Ladens damit ausstattet, weil...
Ich finde auch, krasser kann man den zivilisatorischen Verfall unserer Gesellschaft nicht darstellen.
So reden wir mittlerweile. Vor zwei Wochen haben wir noch ganz normal gesprochen. Da haben wir noch so... Hey, Ponygates! Hey, Ponygates!
Im alten Rom war der Steinmetz der höchst angesehene Beruf. Das waren Künstler, die waren weltbekannt, die haben wirklich aus Marmor die Menschen geschaffen, die haben fallenden Stoffen getreht, wo man wirklich darüber gestrichen hat und dachte, wow, das ist unfassbar, der menschliche Körper zelebriert in Marmor gefasst, unfassbar. und heute kauft er das für 3,99 Euro irgendwie aus Pappmaché bei Dehner, wo ich mir einfach denke so, das war früher einfach mal.
Es gibt aber auch noch Unge und Revy. Und Gron, ja, und German Let's Play und so, das möchte man hier sagen. Aber das ist tatsächlich ein kompletter Verfall. Verfall. Was ist denn mit Steinmetzen los? Die machen Grabsteine. Friedhöfe, ja, Grabsteine. Tatsächlich habe ich gelesen, immer mehr Wolte wollen Kremationen haben, Kremarien. und das ist kulturell nicht gedacht. In unserem Kulturkreis sind Kremationen nicht gedacht, traditionell. Es gibt keine Tradition und Rituale für Kremationen. Das ist etwas, das es nicht gibt. Es wurde angeglichen mittlerweile. Es gibt auch eine Niederlassung der Urne. Tatsächlich, ja, aber beim Wikipedia-Artikel unter Trauer, ich habe Trauer gegoogelt, gab es tatsächlich einen Abschnitt, der heisst, es entstehen neue Rituale zur Beisetzung von Kremationen. Man fützt dreimal hoch und ruft und hot, hot, hot, und hot. Man muss sich an neue Traditionen ausdenken. Es gibt ja gewisse Dinge, so Duelle oder zum Beispiel.
Früher mega ritualisiert, man konnte Leute zum Duell herausfordern, du hattest eine Pistole dabei, dann gab es da so ein Feld, dann wurden die erschossen, dann so und jetzt weg. Aber da gibt es ja irgendwie auch neue Sachen, wo neue Rituale entstehen, wo es dann vielleicht auch mal irgendwie so Regelbücher gibt. Es gibt ja irgendwo bestimmt ein Regelbuch für Duelle, wo dann drinsteht, genau so läuft. Aber gibt es sowas heute auch noch? Aber Statuen ist ein guter Punkt.
Über, genau, von welchem heute lebenden Menschen gibt es in 100 Jahren eine Statue? So. Also, jetzt möchte ich mich zunächst bedanken für diese Frage. Und ich als jemand, der sich damit schon lange beschäftigt hat und oft nächtelange herangesessen hat in diesem Problem, möchte kurz einmal ausführen, was es hieß, eine Statue von sich zu hinterlassen.
Einem war es wichtig, unendlich zu leben. Es war wichtig, der Nachwelt zu zeigen, wer man war.
In Stein gemeisselt.
In Stein gemeisselt ist er auch ein geflügter Ausgleich, den man heute noch kennt.
Und das wollte man, man wollte der Nachwelt von sich erzählen, man wollte unendlich da sein, man wollte nicht unsterblich sein. Und das ist in der heutigen Welt auf andere Weise möglich, einfacher. Zum Beispiel, indem man ein Musikalbum herausbringt oder ein Memewirft. Oder aber, sagen wir mal, zumindest auf der Bravo 75,
Bravo jetzt 75 einmal im Background, uh, Rissama singt. Ja. Das ist halt auf andere Weise möglich. Deswegen ist das Prinzip Statue irrelevant, weil jemand, der so berühmt ist, dass man nicht sagen würde, what, der riecht eine Statue, wo man sagen würde, okay, es ist die logische Konsequenz der richtet Statue. Jemand, der so berühmt ist, hat sich automatisch schon so quasi eingefärcht in die Geschichtsbücher, dass man das Statue nicht mehr braucht als einzigen Weg, um quasi unsterblich zu sein. Aber ich meine, es wurden von Politikernern wurden doch auch, also es gibt zum Beispiel eine Adenauer-Statue
in Berlin. Karl Markt.
Das heißt, es gibt auch, also ich glaube, von Kohl
ist keine Statue, aber vom
Springergebäude in Berlin gibt es auch so Skulpturen
vom Kopf von Kohl.
Das heißt, es gibt schon noch
Entschuldigung,
ey, wir haben gerade mietig noch gesagt,
wir wollen jetzt jeden Gag mitnehmen.
Und jetzt kann ich mich nicht hier hinsetzen und diesen Gag nicht machen. Der Mann ist tot, okay? Und deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob überhaupt noch Statuen gebaut werden. Zum Beispiel so etwas wie Steve Jobs. Gibt es da eine Statue? So eine Rolli. Ich meine, die ist dann halt recht teuer. Ach komm, Leute, es funktioniert für mich einfach nicht.
Eistatue. Ey, wir sind heute ganz
gesellschaftskritisch. Ja. So ganz tagesaktuell
eklig. Ich glaube, der Personenkult
kommt auch außer Mode,
weil ich glaube, das Vergessen
ist in unserer Gesellschaft nicht
mehr präsent. Die Römer dachten
sich, Freunde, wenn wir
jetzt keine Statue bauen, kennt den Kerl in zehn
Jahren niemand mehr. Wir sind alle tot, weil Lebenserwartung ist vielleicht neun. Wir sind alle straight tot in ein paar Jahren. Deswegen, lass uns jetzt bitte schnell eine Statue bauen, sonst ist der weg. Aber heute hat man die Gefahr, also niemand macht sich ernsthaft Gedanken, dass jemand Steve Jobs vergessen könnte, weil es gibt einen Wikipedia-Artikel, es gibt einen Film. Auch er selber nicht. Und Leute, die so weit gebracht haben, dass sie eine Statue bekommen, irgendwann in damaliger Zeit, waren auch Narzissten, klar. Also niemand kommt so hoch, vielleicht sei er dann damals, ja gut, Stammensbild nicht gebraut. Stimmt, die haben sich das ja selber bauen lassen. Nee, erst nach dem Tod. Oft haben die sich das oft selber bauen lassen, doch. Nee, aber zum Beispiel, wenn du so Statuen auf Pferden hast, dann zeigen die Hufhaltung der Pferde, zeigt ja an, wie die Person gestorben ist. Wenn beide Hufe vorne in der Luft sind, dann ist er in der Schlacht gestorben. oder wenn ein Fuß auf dem Boden ist, dann ist er seine Verletzungen aus dem Krieg erlegt. So was ist kein Witz, das ist einfach wahr. Ich hab Geld gemacht, wenn das Pferd auch an der Seite liegt, aber es ist einfach faktisch korrekt. Gut, und deswegen ist es... Deswegen muss das ja posthum errichtet worden sein. Das war eine posthum errichte Fiktion. Deswegen
ganz... Ich kann es uns mittlerweile...
Ich kann es selber nicht mehr ertragen.
Leute, wenn ihr gerade das Gefühl habt, was ist jetzt anders
mittlerweile und soll ich es ausmachen vielleicht, soll ich die anderen Folgen
noch hören? Mir geht es gerade sehr... Ich kann es selber ganz schwer
ertragen, wie wir gerade reden. Ja.
Nee, deswegen, ich glaube, die
vergessene Angst gilt in Vergessenheit
und deswegen ist es nicht mehr nötig, heute Tatort zu bauen. Gags sind ein grosses
Problem, weil aus aktuellem Anlass
ist es
nun mal so, dass
Vielen Dank. Wissenangst gilt in Vergessenheit und deswegen ist es nicht mehr nötig, heute Stattung zu bauen. Gags sind ein großes Problem, weil aus aktuellem Anlass ist es nun mal so, dass ich weiß um jemanden, der sich einen bestimmten Grabstein gewünscht hat, aber das umzusetzen wäre wahnsinnig lächerlich. Es gibt nämlich bei Friedhöfen, komischerweise stellen die vorne die Steinmetze nicht mehr die normalen Grabsteine hin, sondern die er weiss, dass die Steinmetze diese Grabsteine anbieten, sondern so crazy Grabsteine, so Pyramiden oder beispielsweise einen grossen Elefanten. Jetzt kenne ich jemanden, der sich gewünscht hat, diesen grossen Elefanten als Grabstein zu bekommen, wo aber jetzt alle Verwandten geschlossen sagen, Das ist aber viel. Aber dieser Elefant, ich meine, das macht auch alle da rumliegenden Gräber lächerlich. Das ist ein grosser Mittelstand. Auch der Friedhof-Versichter sagt doch, nee, nee, sorry, dieser Elefant ist jetzt nicht das, was wir uns für diesen Friedhof erhoffen. Alle in der Kette sind dagegen, außer die Person, die gestorben ist. Jetzt will man dem aber auch nicht den Wunsch
verwehren, diesen Grabstein
zu nichts. Schwierige Situationen.
Aber ich glaube, ich meine,
diese Person ist tot, die wird jetzt auch nicht merken,
was das für ein Grabstein kommt.
Aber alle Personen,
die anwesend waren, meinen,
ja Leute, aber mein Pizzagrabstein
macht ihr trotzdem, oder?
Leute, alles bricht gerade zusammen. Ich habe euch auch mal gesagt, wenn ich sterbe und ihr dann alle da bei guter Arbeit sitzt oder am Neomagazin sitzt und sagt, Stefan hätte es gewollt, wenn wir weitermachen, hier nochmal offiziell, ich will nicht, dass ihr weitermacht. Ich will nicht, dass ihr das Neomagazin, ich will, dass ihr nichts mehr weitermacht. Auch wenn ihr sagt, ja, wir trauern jetzt und wir lachen jetzt, aber er hätte es so gewollt, dass wir weiter lachen, nein, ich will von euch, dass ihr die ganze Zeit trauert. Du willst, dass das gesamte Medium Deutschland aufhört auf einen Schlag. So, und wer das nicht tut, der widersetzt sich meinem letzten Willen, beziehungsweise nicht meinem letzten Willen, weil ich den jetzt schon äussere und ich habe noch andere Willen danach, aber mein jetzt aktueller Willen. Ja. Man hat es oft nicht in der Hand, was nach seinem Tod
geschieht.
Vielleicht auch doch. Weiss man
alles nicht, weil man weiss so wenig. Woran glaubst du?
Wir machen oft Scherze,
aber ich will ganz ernsthaft von dir wissen,
woran du glaubst. Was
ist nach dem Tod?
Da muss ich leider die langweiligstmögliche Antwort geben.
Nichts, gar nichts. Aber das ist unvorstellbar. Unvorstellbar. Aber auch da der klassische Atheisten-Slogan, das ist halt genauso wie vor der Geburt, das ist auch unvorstellbar und das kann man sich auch nicht vorstellen, aber es war halt mal so, du warst faktisch mal nicht da. Du warst für eine unendlich lange Zeit nicht da. Richtig. Du bist jetzt für eine endliche Zeit da und dann wieder für unendliche Zeit nirgendwo. Wir sind unendliche Zeit nirgendwo. Deswegen ist es halt, ja. Schreib's in die Kommentare. Was passiert nach dem Tod? Die kreativste Antwort gewinnt ein T-Shirt. Bevor ich mir die Frage stelle, gibt es ein Leben nach dem Tod, versuche ich mir die Frage zu stellen, gibt es ein Leben vor dem Tod?
Das ist die langeweilige Antwort.
Das war die langeweilige Antwort.
Was willst du noch machen, bevor du stirbst?
Tatsächlich habe ich es gerade eben noch zu jemandem gesagt, das ist wirklich was, was ich, das einzige, was ich erleben will, bevor ich sterbe, ist Sex, ist es, Aliens zu begegnen. Das einzige, was ich will in meinem Leben.
Okay, ich sehe schon, Stefan liegt im Sterben, Todesbett und wir sagen, Renate, bitte, zieh den Gummi, zieh den Anzug an.
Wir haben es besprochen, es war sein Wunsch.
Nein, ihr könnt mich da noch nicht so verarschen, weil ich habe bis dahin alle Bücher gelesen, ich weiß, wie Aliens aussehen müssten.
Sie besteht aus Gas und sind auf einer niederfrequentigen radioaktiven Ebene sichtbar. Also, ich weiß es. Ciao, ich bin ein Riesenarsch doch im Sterbebett. Aber, also, tatsächlich ist es, weil dann kann ich beruhigt sterben, weil dann weiß ich, ich bin ein noch wesentlich unwichtiger Teil im Gesamtgefüge des Universums, dass es irgendeine Mühe ... Ähm, dass es keine Mühe der Welt lohnt, es sich aufgenommen zu werden, um sich vielleicht unsterblich zu machen, wo wir ja Thema Schator zu werden, wenn es Aliens gibt. Du hast nichts mehr in der Hand. Weil dann gibt es de facto unendlich verschiedene Wesen irgendwo und ich selber habe an mich den Anspruch, mich über meinen Tod hinaus irgendwie zu verwirklichen. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, wenn du jetzt die Wahl hättest, Szenario A, Aliens werden entdeckt eine Woche vor deinem Tod oder Aliens werden entdeckt eine Woche nach deinem Tod. Mir wäre doch wesentlich lieber, wenn sie entdeckt werden nach meinem Tod. Weil wenn ich im Sterben liege und ich sage Aliens und sage, oh nein, ich werde nie rausfinden, also jetzt tun sich ja wahnsinnig viele Fragen auf. Was hören die für Musik, was machen die für Filme, wie viele Geschlechter haben die, aber die stellen sich jetzt ja auch schon. Wie haben die die Probleme, nee, aber jetzt, genau, jetzt sind es Fragen, auf die tatsächlich Antworten kommen, weil es dauert halt jetzt immer irgendwie lange, bis die Strahlen von deren Planeten zu unserem kommen. Und du weißt, okay, all diese Fragen werden jetzt bald beantwortet, aber ich krieg's gerade nicht mehr mit. Das ist auch viel schlimmer, als einfach damit zu leben. Nee, aber wenn du stirbst, weißt du, also... Ja, aber das Wissen, du hast keinen Payoff mehr. Die Unendlichkeit des Universums legt nahe, dass es so ist, dass es noch welche gibt. Wahrscheinlich ist es so, dass wir uns niemals erreichen können aufgrund der Entfernungen und so weiter,
aber doch, also die Unendlichkeit legt es nahe.
Aber es ist ja nicht unendlich.
Ja, auch da gibt es ja Diskussionen,
aber ja, okay, lassen wir das auf sich beruhen.
Die Grösse des Universums legt nahe, dass es so ist.
Ja, aber Grösse macht ja noch keinen Inhalt aus.
Wollen wir weiterreden oder wollen wir an diesem Punkt wieder aufreiten? Du hast eine endliche Menge
an Masse, die beim Urknall vorhanden war. Und du hast eine erscheinbar unendliche Motivation, gerade diesen Gespräch zu beenden. Es liegt nahe, dass es ausserirdische gibt, ausserirdische Lebensformen. Und die Fragen stellst du dir jetzt eh schon alle. Wenn ich sterbe, weiß ich also, dass irgendwann in einer unendlichen Zeit Fragen beantwortet werden, für wen auch immer. Das heißt, dieses Pay-off hast du dann eh nicht. Ob das jetzt eine Woche nach meinem Tod oder drei Milliarden Jahre nach meinem Tod passiert, ist egal. In dem Moment, wo es vor deinem Tod passiert ist, ist es die einzige Möglichkeit, wo du was davon hast. Ja, Moment, aber es ist doch besser, Hunger zu haben, als Hunger zu haben und vor dir steht Essen, das du nicht essen kannst. Und genau so ist es doch. Du hast Wissenshunger, aber du hast das Essen schon vor, dir kannst du es aber nicht essen, weil du gleich stirbst.
Aber du siehst es, nee, also nein, vor allem, weil das keine Frage beantwortet. Also das ist insofern ein unpassendes Beispiel, weil du halt allein durch den Fakt, dass Aliens entdeckt werden, schon so viele Fragen, die Gewissheit hast. Ja, du hast einen gewissen Teilpayoff, ja, aber den Gr doch, genau, klar, Grossteil nicht, aber die Gewissheit, dass du ein wesentlich unbedeutenderer Teil des Ganzen bist. Und das finde ich einfach beruhigend. Das finde ich so beruhigend, dass ich dann gut sterben könnte. Und ich würde auch, wenn jetzt heute eine Alien-Version stattfinden, klar würde ich so lange versuchen zu überleben, wie es geht, aber wenn ich sterbe, dann ist es auch okay. Weil das Einzige, was ich will in meinem Leben, ist, mich über meinen Tod hinaus zu verwirklichen. Und wenn das dann in die Unmöglichkeit rückt, dann sehe ich auch keinen Sinn mehr. Gut, ich dachte als Antwort eher an sowas wie, du würdest gerne mal auf dem Himalaya steigen oder so, aber auch gute Antwort. Ja, vielen Dank, vielen Dank dafür. Ach ja, Aliens. Ganz kurz, es gab doch zum Thema Außerirdische, es wurde doch mal diese Platte in den Weltraum geschossen mit den ganzen so... Mit den Black Eyed Peas. Tatsächlich sind die da drauf. Ja, mit den Black Eyed Peas und mit Beethoven und so und wo halt irgendwie so die wichtigsten Formeln, die die Menschen herausgefunden haben, drauf sind und so das Wichtigste, was die Menschen geschafft haben. Wann gibt es da ein Update? Wann sagt man, okay, jetzt 2.0, jetzt kommt eine neue Platte mit, jetzt das neue Album der Black Eyed Peas ist draußen, das müssen die auch mitkriegen. Ich glaube, die haben jetzt, zweite Staffel Seinfeld, die haben jetzt gerade, hat dieses, jetzt habe ich Voyager oder so, hat jetzt gerade das Sonnensystem verlassen, so um jetzt. Das ist ja gar nichts, ey. Das ist ja so lame, das wird nie irgendwo ankommen. Aber es ist schon trotzdem kunstcool. Vor allem schicken wir ja auch, es gibt ja SETI, das ist The Search for Extraterrestrial Intelligence, ist irgendwo von der Universität Kalifornien oder so wird das immer gemacht. Und die suchen halt danach aktiv und die schicken die ganze Zeit so ein Signal ins All. Und in diesem Signal geben die Preis, wo wir sind, wie unser DNA aufgebaut ist, wie Grossmenschen sind, worin sie leben und wo und wovon das Signal geschickt wurde. Und das alles kann man ganz einfach mit Nullen und Einsen dechifrieren, da weißt du genau, was das für ein Muster ist und schickt die Anleitung, wie man es liest, quasi mit. Das kann jede Lebensform, also statistisch fast jede, die meisten Lebensformen können das dann entschlüsseln. Und das ist schon auch irgendwie gruselig, weil da gab es auch damals so eine moralische Diskussion, ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist, das zu verraten. Um die Position zu verraten. Ja. Ich sehe einfach nur so ein Planeten voller Biber. Und dann so ein Biber und dann so Bip, Bip, Bip, Bip, Bip, Bip, und der Biber nur so. Und nie wieder hat man was von ihm gehört. Und dem Black-Ein-Peace gehört. Er hat kurz mit dem Kopf genickt, aber dachte dann so, ach ja, das sind ein bisschen veraltete Beats. Ja, so 2006, sorry. Aber ich glaube, in so einer Aliensuche zu arbeiten ist doch... Also ich glaube, ich bin ein Mensch, der, wenn er keine Deadlines hat, nichts tut. Ja. Und wenn ich jetzt nicht sagen müsste, hey, der Sketch muss morgen fertig sein, würde ich ihn den Rest meines Lebens nicht schreiben. Ja, selbst dann hast du arge Probleme. Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt wirklich arbeite und man sagt so, und Aliens schon gefunden? Nee, okay, wir sind uns nächstes Jahr wieder. Aliens gefunden? Nee, okay, wir sind uns nächstes Jahr. Du hast keine Motivation, wirklich daran zu arbeiten. Aber du suchst nach dem coolsten, nach der coolsten Antwort aller Zeiten. Ja, hast aber auch eine unglaublich geringe Motivation, weil niemand erwartet, niemand sagt so, echt jetzt keine Aliens, Leute. Jeder sagt so, ja, da dachten wir schon, schade, das nächste Jahr. Deswegen, du hast null Motivation und jemand wie ich würde einfach sagen so, ach ja, freue ich jetzt am Freitag, ich komme, ich mache mal Homeoffice am Freitag, Freunde. Ja, aber du musst doch hier die Satelliten ausrichten. Ja, mache ich Homeoffice so. Kannst du auch von zu Hause? Kannst du auch von zu Hause. Ich schicke euch eine Mail. Und dann schläfst du halt bis 13 Uhr, dann denkst du, ach ja, jetzt erst mal ein Kaffee. Und so eine Uhr haben, so Tage ohne Pfund. Ja, und einfach so seit dem Urknall einfach so 60 Milliarden Jahre. Tage seit dem letzten Pfund, wäre vielleicht lustiger. Das stimmt, ja. Weil das genau so lange wäre.. Fuck ey, diese zwei Wochen werfen einen ganz schön raus so. Ja, das ist hart. Was glaubst du, wie lange müsstest du eine Podcastpause machen, bis du alles verlernt hast, was du kannst? Das ist eine gute Frage. Nach meinen Schlittschuss gilt zu urteilen, ziemlich genau zwölf Jahre. Ja, das stimmt, aber manche Sachen verlernt man nicht. Ich komme mal richtig gut die Schl, es wird zu laufen. Ja, du musst dich räuspern, das haben wir alle verstanden.
Okay, sorry.
Mein Gott.
Aber das ist echt brutal.
Ich lerne ja gerade Klavier, aber es ist so brutal frustrierend.
Es klingt egal, was du gerade lernst, es klingt immer lustig, ich lerne gerade, es klingt so, ich lerne gerade Gehen.
Es klingt immer so ein bisschen lächerlich, aber ich freue mich über dich.
Aber es ist so brutal frustrierend, weil du setzt dich hin und du lernst zwei Stunden lang und am Ende kannst du, sagen wir mal, acht Takte des Stücks kannst du und kannst du spielen. Und eine Woche später setzt du dich hin und du kannst nichts. Du hast vergessen, also nicht nur können deine, kannst du es technisch nicht mehr. Du hast vergessen, womit man die Tasten drückt. Du drückst auf deinem Schreibtisch irgendwo rum, dann denkst du nichts ab. Ach scheiße, fuck. Und du denkst dir an dem Punkt einfach, ja dann können wir es lassen, du musstest jetzt nochmal zwei Stunden arbeiten, um wieder auf dem Punkt zu sein, wo du das letzte Mal aufgehörst, um dann weiterzumachen. Mir ist schon klar, dass man irgendwann auch die Fähigkeit, Dinge zu behalten, steigert und man einfach sein Gehirn so umpolen muss, dass es sich auch Dinge merken kann, weil Gitarrenstücke, die ich vor drei Jahren gelernt habe, kann ich heute noch blind, völlig einfach eingebrannt in mir, einfach weil ich dafür die richtigen Synapsen habe, weil ich auch einfach gut Dinge neu lernen kann, wenn sie in dem Kontext stattfinden, in dem ich schon mal Dinge gelernt habe. Das heißt, das muss alles noch passieren für Klavier, bis dahin, es ist so fucking frustrierend, ey, es ist richtig frustrierend, aber, ja, man muss dranbleiben. Ich bin auch noch nicht weitergekommen mit meinen Posauenunenskills. Ich habe mir überlegt, das ist ja mein großes, das ist die Stephan-Tietze-Musikschule, sich jedes Jahr das billigste Musikinstrument einer Art zu besorgen. Nächstes Jahr werde ich mir eine Trompete kaufen. Gibt jetzt von Thomann eine Plastiktrompete? Ja, es gibt immer, also Thomann ist die beste Seite der Welt. Wirklich, das ist deine Aussage. Thomann ist die beste Seite der Welt. YouTube. Google. Amazon. Aber gut, Thomann ist auch gut. Thomann ist eine richtig gute Seite. Ich spreche in Extrem. Ich funktioniere nur in Extrem. Jedes Jahr hole ich mir von einem Musikinstrument die billigste Variante. Weil ich weiß, es ist eine Phase, die werde ich überstehen, nach zwei Wochen ist die vorbei und ich habe mir jetzt schon die billigste Geige gekauft, die billigste Trompete gekauft. Du hast eine Geige, das wusste ich gar nicht. Noch die billigste Geige der Welt. Wie viel hat die gekostet? Die sind immer noch relativ feuer, so 112 Euro oder so kosten die da. Geige ist das nicht, ja. Oder 160? Die billigste Ukuleleipchen gekauft und nächstes Jahr ist entweder das billigste Banjo oder die billigste Trompete dran. Weiß ich noch nicht genau. Und da lerne ich dann immer Musikinstrumente. Weil ich glaube, das hilft auch, ist auch fürs Gehirn glaube ich nicht so schlecht. Ist eine gute Investition, also Musikinstrumente sind eh eine gute Investition immer. Ja, ich bin auch wahnsinnig stolz auf meine Grosscousine, die jetzt anfängt Saxophon zu spielen und die jetzt irgendwie, die ist jetzt gerade in der vierten, fünften Klasse und die hat jetzt schon das grosse Saxophon bekommen und wurde jetzt in die Big Band aufgenommen, zwei Jahre bevor normalerweise Leute in die Big Band aufgenommen wurden und spielt jetzt einfach, sieht einfach ein bisschen lächerlich aus, weil sie klein ist, wie alt ist man in der fünften Klasse, zehn oder so und hat so grosse Saxophon, spielt einfach in der-Bär mit den großen Jungs, die glaube ich alle ein bisschen angefisst sind. Aber das ist schon cool. Weil das ist cool. Musik ist immer cool. Auf jeden Fall, Musik ist cool. Nicht nur anhören, sondern auch selber spielen. Mach doch mal einen Podcast. Musikalisch kann auch lustig, sag ich an der Stelle. Ich habe mir letztens überlegt, ob ich das... Ich habe irgendwie Bock zu streamen. Ich habe Bock zu streamen, ich weiß nicht warum, aber irgendwie baut es entweder einen Karriereplan B, den ich mir gerade aus irgendwelchen Gründen suchen möchte. Kann ich mir nicht erklären, wie du darauf kommst. Dass sie mir einfach sagt, weil streamen ist mega leicht, wenn du das einfach ein Jahr lang machst, dann hast du deine 10.000 Follower und dann kannst du es auch machen, um was zu erreichen, ohne jetzt einfach nur für dich hinzustreamen. Deswegen dachte ich mir, ich dachte entwederweder stream ich Dota, was aber niemand interessiert, weil ich bin schlecht und es interessiert niemanden. Der wirst du auch nicht besser, ne? Oder ich mache es wie Dan Harmon, weil Dan Harmon hat gesagt, er muss abnehmen und macht immer Sport und um sich zu motivieren, streamt er das. Das ist das Beste der Welt. Und da dachte ich mir so, das mache ich auch mit Klavierspielen, dass ich mein Klavierspielen streame und dann irgendwie auch, weil ich glaube, mein größter Antrieb ist Narzissmus.
Und dann muss ich mich auch anstrengen, weil dann will ich gut aussehen. Und ich glaube, es ist ja nur clever, einfach auch seine Schwächen oder seine, sag ich mal, seine Charakterzüge, die ihm vielleicht nicht so gut gefallen, auch so zu nutzen, um am Ende sich selber auszutricken, um am Ende ein gutes Ergebnis zu haben. Nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, ich nehme ab jetzt, indem ich nichts mehr esse, indem ich die ganze Zeit filme und nicht mehr esse und nie wieder esse. Du wirst aber jetzt auch regelmäßig pumpen, mein Freund. Was habe ich heute gehört? Was habe ich heute gehört, was der gute Mann stemmt? Was habe ich gehört? Ich stemme 10 Kilo! Nicht schlecht. Für jemanden, der vor ein paar Wochen noch die Stange alleine in die Hunde aufgestreckt hat. Aber jetzt nenn mich jetzt dumm, nenn mich doof, nenn mich dummer, rassistisches Arschloch. Aber die Bewegung, mit der du diesen Benchpress machst, die brauche ich im Alltag, die ganze Zeit brauche ich im Alltag. Du drückst von der Brust etwas weg nach oben. Das ist doch dieselbe Bewegung wie ein Liegestütz. Exakt. Aber in einem Liegestütz drückst du doch dein Körpergewicht nach oben, was auch viel mehr ist als 10 Kilo. Also warum kannst du nicht viel mehr? Du kannst doch ein Liegestütz. Ich kann kein Liegestütz. Das ist die einfache Erklärung. Du kannst doch ein Liegestütz. Ich kann ein Liegestütz. Ja eben, aber du musst es ja nur einmal drücken. Ja, nee. Aber du wiegst doch 80 Kilo. Wir machen 12 Bewegungen, mache ich. Aber warum kannst du nur 80 K klima liegestütz aber nur zehn kilo benchpress das verstehe ich nicht wiederholungen geht es ja ich muss dreimal zwölf wiederholungen ich könnte nicht sechsunddreissig mal mein eigenes körpergewicht in die luft strecken und ich wiege deutlich mehr als 80 kilo bei push-ups hast du ja nur einen winkel da drückst du ja nicht dein ganzes körpergewicht hoch du hast ja so ein drück bis nach dem ein, du hast ja so ein, das kommt auch noch dazu, aber ich glaube, du wirkst schon wesentlich mehr als 10 Kilo, drückst du in die Höhe. Ja, dein Kopf wiegt, was wiegt dein Kopf? Mein Kopf wiegt eine Menge. Ich würde sagen, solide 9 Kilo. Nee, vor allem wegen der Metallbär, die mir eingesetzt wurde, weil ich als Kind gegen einen Baum gerauern bin, die ist deutlich schwerer. Ich kenne jemanden, bei dem ist ein Kind gegen einen Baum gerauern, war dann tot. Was war das denn für ein Baum? Peugeot-Baum oder was? Bitte? Was? Peugeot-Baum? Ja, das ist eigentlich kein Baum, sondern ein Auto. Die Gag-Erklärschule, wie Gags nicht funktionieren sollten. Die Negativbeispiele heute. Der Peugeot-Baum. So, was ist dir vorgefallen?
Der Krebsbaum, könnte man sagen.
Ihm standen die ganze Welt der Baum-Gags, der Kinder-Gags, der Tod-Gags, er hat sich für Peugeot-Baum entschieden.
Möchtest du kurz erklären, wie das dazu kam?
Ja, rückblickend, glaube ich, hätte ich eher sowas wie Aids-Baum oder Krebsbaum sagen sollen.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht, das ist wie wenn du jetzt sagst, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, es hat irgendwas passiert und dann sagst du, ja, sein Onkel hat das gemacht, dass du eigentlich ein etwas düsteres Ding implizierst. Genauso würde ich sagen, es ging Baum gelaufen, ah, ja, und wer hat den Baum gefahren? So, du implizierst ein düsteres Ficksextrad. Das heißt, du hast an daran gedacht, dann an Automarke gedacht, dann kam Peugeot als erstes raus und dann der Peugeot-Baum. Also die Lease... Es war nicht ideal, es war nicht ideal, das gebe ich ganz ehrlich zu, aber ich finde es auch ein bisschen hart, wie ich gerade reingenommen werde. Aber gut, hey, nur so wird man besser. Nur so wird man besser. Ja, du bist in Zeitdruck, habe ich gemerkt. Gehst du auch noch pumpen oder was? Der einzige Grund, warum ich gerade eher aus dem Meeting herausgegangen bin, den ich mitgeschleppt habe und wir jetzt eher schon aufnehmen, ist, weil ich nicht nachher um 20 Uhr zu Hause erst sein will, um dann nicht mehr ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen, weil dann ist meine Ausrede zu gut, nicht mehr ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen. Das stimmt, das ist etwas tatsächlich. Und deswegen will ich jetzt lieber eher zu Hause sein, um keine Ausrede zu haben. Ich bin so wenig diszipliniert. Nee, aber das ist tatsächlich wichtig. Ich habe jetzt gemerkt, ich baller mir, wir trinken ja seit langem Huel. Du bist besser als ich darin. Du bist wesentlich selbstdiszipliniert als ich. Und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich dadurch relativ solide abnehme. Und damit ist meine Motivation, Sport zu machen, negativ. Absolut, unter Null. Auf gar keinen Fall. Und das, also ich glaube, ich werde nie mehr Sport machen. Ihr merkt, Fit kann auch lustig, sagen wir mal eher zu so einem, Fit kann auch wabbeln. Fit kann auch weggelassen werden geworden. Ja, absolut. Fit ist auch entbehrlich. Fit, dich schaut eh niemand an. So was in der Ecke. Genau wie ich heute gesagt habe, was unfassbar lustig war, weil ich ein Genie bin, ich habe gesagt, dann habe ich irgendwann Muskeln, dann kann ich irgendwann die 50 Kilo stemmen und dann, was dann? Ich werde meinen Lifestyle nicht ändern, ich werde nicht irgendwann anfangen, Leute zu verprüfen auf der Strasse oder werde auch nicht anfangen, Türsteher zu sein. Was mache ich, wofür mache ich das eigentlich alles? Attraktivität, Gesundheit, okay. Aber bist du mit deinem aktuellen äusserlichen Aussehen unzufrieden? Ja, absolut, klar. Oder geht es dir nur darum, wie du dich fühlst, dass du mein Haltung ist furchtbar. Ich habe mich noch nicht mal von der Seite gesehen. Ja, das darf man nicht machen. Profil, ne? Alles, was so Hals- und Nackendinger angeht. Ich habe damals die einzige Staffel Dschungelcamp, glaube ich, die ich gesehen habe. Und da war dabei dieser, wie heisst der, dieser Quizmaster, der dann gewonnen hat am Ende. Walter Freibald. Hat nicht gewonnen, aber... Und der hat eine unglaublich krumme Körperhaltung. Und ich konnte mir das nicht angucken. Weil ich immer so selbst gewahr wurde. Und jemand, der fechtet, hat mir mal gezeigt, wie man richtig steht. Und wenn ich versuche, richtig zu stehen, muss ich wirklich mit ganzer Kraft meine Schultern nach hinten drücken. Das ist Aufwand, Kraftaufwand. Keine Spur von Natürlichkeit, sondern ich bin schon so krumm, dass natürliches Stehen für mich Kraft erfordert. Das sieht auch komisch aus, das sieht auch nicht natürlich aus. Also nicht nur, dass ich nicht reflexartig mache, sondern muss es wirklich Kraft aufwenden. Und da komme ich da nicht mehr raus. Ich komme noch nie wieder zurück. Also ich kann doch jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag meine Schultern, sondern ich sehe aus wie so, komme da voll Idiot. Es ist ja auch aus, ob du jemanden nachmachen willst, der eine richtige Haltung hat. Ja, es funktioniert nicht mehr. Du siehst aus wie ein Alien, was irgendwie dem beigebracht wurde, zu gehen wie ein Mensch. Ja, der Körper ist der Schwachpunkt des Menschen. Hätten Menschen keine Körper, wäre alles besser. Ich glaube, so in ein paar Jahren sind wir nur noch Maschinen mit einem Gehirn? Oder sagen wir mal, das Einzige, was wir brauchen, das Einzige, was uns auszeichnet, ist unser Gehirn. Oder nicht? Nein, natürlich nicht. Auch noch aus der östlichen Merklinik. Die Frage, die du stellst, ist, wird unsere Gesellschaft immer oberflächlicher? Ist äusserliches Aussehen in der Zukunft wichtiger als heute? Und ich würde sagen, hm, interessante Frage. Eine Frage fürs nächste Mal. Eine Frage, die nicht... Das einfach langsam in so ein ernsthaftes Gesellschaftsmagazin an, was einfach schrecklich ist. Zwischen zwei alten Männern, die jeglichen Bezug zur Realität verloren haben. Lass uns über die modernen Medien reden. Nee, lass uns nicht, wenn ich in so einen Podcast reinhöre und dann so, ja, lass uns über Politik reden. Nee, einfach nicht. Wir reden wieder... Ich habe gestern Wieso geguckt, keine Ahnung warum. Wieso? Dieses ZDF-Magazin, dieses Braucher-Magazin, und dann hat der Typ anmoderiert mit, ja, ein neuer Trend ist in den Schulen eingezogen in Deutschland, alle haben sie diese kleinen Geräte, die sich in die Hand drehen lassen, Fidget Spinder. Und ich dachte mir so, oh Gott, du bist gerade das Klischee eines alten Mannes, der über jugendliche Sachen spricht. Das ist so furchtbar. Das ist natürlich eine Scheisshaltung. Erwachsene dürfen nicht sagen. Ja, aber du gibst einmal das Wort auf YouTube ein, schaust dir ein Video an und weißt, wie es ausgesprochen wird. Es ist nicht so schwierig. Fidget Spinder. Es ist nicht immer falsch ausgesprochen, es ist einfach ein falsches Wort. Vielleicht meint ihr aber auch was anderes. Sie haben sich leider für den falschen Trend entschieden. Der Beitrag ging dann tatsächlich um Fidget Spinder, aber es ist eine andere Geschichte. Ich finde das auch so gut, dass das sofort auch als therapeutische Wirkung, dass diese therapeutische Wirkung dieser Fidget Spinder immer betont wird. Das ist ja für ADS-Menschen zur Entspannung und so, warum betont man das ständig? Ja, jedes Gerät kann irgendwie therapeutisch eingesetzt werden, auch einen Ball kannst du irgendwie in der Reha einsetzen oder in der Physiotherapie. Aber so what, es ist primär ein Spielzeug. Warum muss man das so überbetonen, dass es ja auch etwas Besonderes hat? Das ist ein Spielzeug. Aber als ich ganz klein war und ein Gameboy hatte, und da hat man, da hat man begrenzte Funktionen, da hat man den Eltern das gezeigt und die Eltern haben gesagt, wow, das war so, das findet ihr gerade cool, okay, paar Jahre später, Tamagotchi wurde innen wieder, Tamagotchi hat es den Eltern gezeigt, das ist alles, was es kann, okay, das ist jetzt, dann hat man immer Bayblades gehabt, Kreisel, das ist alles, was sie können, man kann sie kreiseln und mittlerweile hat man Drehdinger, die man einfach nur irgendwie gefühlt sind. Die Jugendtrends werden immer primitiver. Man hat einfach einen Würfel wieder in der Hand. Einfach nur so einen Stock, den man dann so cool flippen kann, wenn man so Sachen hochwirft, und dann drehen kann. Alter, schneidet diesen Kommentar auf Lohnting gerade aus und guckt fünf Jahre in die Zukunft, da sind diese Stöcke in. Ja, es könnte tatsächlich sein, aber die sind dann wahnsinnig gut für Menschen mit Autisten. Tatsächlich gibt es ja diese drei Stöcke, einfach nur drei Stöcke, wo man dann nur zwei Stöcken diesen einen in der Mitte balancieren muss. Du meinst Essstäbchen. Nein, diese drei Stöcke, drei Stöcke allein schon hat man drei Stöcke in der Hand, zwei Stöcke in der Hand, einen in der Luft und dann muss man den so hin und her schwingen, dass der nicht runterfällt. Ich glaube, die Trends gehen auch in so eine Richtung, wo einfach dann irgendwann gar keine neuen
Produkte mehr gebaut werden müssen,
sondern man einfach Löffel verkauft.
Der neue Trend, Löffel, und dann kann man so Löffel
so cool so spinnen auf seinem Handgelenk.
Die sind jetzt blau. Und dann wirft man die so um und dann alle verkaufen
Löffel und die sind einfach Löffel,
aber es ist gerade einfach innen.
War jetzt eigentlich die ganze Zeit die Klimaanlage auf dem...
Ja, war maximal an. Das ist der einzige
Grund, warum man merkt, dass Sommer ist, wenn man sich das
in 18 Jahren nochmal anhört, ist, dass die Klimaanlage
konstant im Hintergrund langsam... Die Folgen, wo es
die im Hintergrund macht.
Aber da die Leute
ja auch Klimaanlage haben, wenn sie es hören,
dann cancelt sich das raus.
Verstehst du, wie es funktioniert, Klimaanlagen?
Ich hab's mal verstanden. Da ist
irgendein Material drin, das
Energie draus zieht. Eiswürfel, eine Menge Eiswürfel und es kommt Luft rein. Weil in der Summe erzeugt doch ein Kühlschrank zum Beispiel mehr Wärme als Kälte. Wenn du den Kühlschrank offen stehen lässt, wäre das Haus wärmer. Genau, aber du fokussierst halt die Kälte auf einen Punkt in dem Kühlschrank. Richtig. Das heißt, in der Summe gibt es eigentlich gar keine Kälte, sondern du saugst, du splittest es sozusagen nur auf. Du splittest es nur auf eigentlich so. In die kalten Teile und die warmen Teile, aber die warmen Teile haben immer noch mehr. Du meinst, die warmen Moleküle und die kalten Moleküle splittest du auf, dass eine Kernfusik entsteht, die Kälte erzeugt. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass auf einem abstrakten Level das sogar stimmt, auf irgendwo, auf einer Art.
Könnte das sogar stimmen.
Stimmt nicht alles auf irgendeinem abstrakten Wege?
Ja, das stimmt tatsächlich.
Man muss nur tief genug irgendwie in die Quantenphysik gehen und irgendwann ist jeder Satz wahr.
Und deswegen ist Wahrheit auch ein wirklich tricky Subject.
Und das war die unsympathischste Folge des Podcasts, Ufo. Vielen. Florian Will und Stammatize sagen danke. Ihr habt euch die Rückkehr gewünscht. Bereut ihr sie schon? Falls ja, schreibt uns an patreon.com slash das Podcast-UFO. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine fantastische Woche und sehen euch wieder, wenn es natürlich wieder... Aber man muss jetzt jetzt tatsächlich sagen, nächste Woche kommt noch eine Folge und dann sind wir erstmal im Urlaub. Und dann gibt es das YouTube-UFO, denn wir fahren wieder nach New York und dann gibt es eine neue Folge des YouTube-Ufo. Und ihr könnt uns ja gerne Tipps schicken, wo wir hingehen sollen in New York und was wir machen sollen für euch in New York und welche Produkte ihr getestet haben möchtet und was ihr alles wünscht. Auf jeden Fall und ernst gemeinte Tipps, denn wir sind eine Woche in New York und wir haben ja jetzt, nachdem wir das erste Mal da waren und dann total gehypt und gehypt und gehypt und gehypt. Können wir jetzt so ein bisschen tiefer gehen in die Stadt unseres Herzens, können wir ein bisschen tiefer schürfen und falls ihr tatsächliche Insider-Tipps habt oder irgendwelche Restaurants oder Lokale oder irgendwas, gibt es immer, natürlich mal Tipps geben. Clubs, Tanzclubs. Wir gehen überall hin, Tanzcafés, einfach mal, warum nicht? Kennst du das Prinzip Tanzkarte noch? Nächste Woche klären wir das Prinzip Tanzkarte. Tanzkarte, freue mich drauf. Viel Spaß. Das war Stefan Tietze, macht's gut.
Und flut die Woche.
Ciao, im ab.